[Music]
many children across the
english-speaking world grew up hearing
mother goose nursery rhymes about mice
running up clocks old women living in
shoes and one unfortunate egg by the
name of humpty dumpty but have you ever
heard the rhyme about the crooked man
most of us who heard that particular
poem remember it like this there was a
crooked man and he walked a crooked mile
he found a crooked sixpence against a
crooked style he bought a crooked cat
which caught a crooked mouse and they
all live together in a little crooked
house a little bit odd but hey most
nursery rhymes are when have you ever
seen a little girl sitting on a tuffet
eating some curds and whey what even is
a tuffet honestly what are curds and
whey
let's just move on residents of the
sleepy english hamlet of tembi and
oxfordshire hear a more menacing version
of the rhyme about the crooked man sung
as a song on playgrounds shared in
hushed tones when the grown-ups aren't
listening it goes like this there lived
a crooked man who made a crooked deal he
kept a crooked cane and his catch in
crooked creel he stole a crooked child
who cried a crooked squeal and that
crooked little man was broken on the
wheel it sounds just as inscrutible as
any other nursery rhyme but there is a
dark tone to it that seems a bit out of
place especially when you compare it to
the other somewhat cheery version this
creepy alternative to the crooked man
nursery rhyme seems to only be found in
the town of tembi and unfortunately for
the residents of that town there is a
deadly truth behind its words many years
ago the scp foundation became aware of a
mysterious pattern in this unassuming
town every 12 years over a period of
roughly 70 days something horrible would
happen to townspeople who happened to be
alone and indoors after dark when they
were discovered by a neighbor a family
member a friend or even the police they
would be unresponsive suffering from
full-body paralysis or appearing to be
effectively brain dead this was not the
most unusual aspect of the phenomenon
though the victims were all grotesquely
transformed their long bones covered in
dozens of compound fractures combined
with excess cartilage and osseous tissue
their limbs would become distended
stretched and deformed into long gnarled
appendages like the limbs of an ancient
tree one of the recovered victims had a
forearm measured at over 2.4 meters long
another had to be placed in a specially
outfitted hospital bed as his spine and
legs had stretched to the point where he
was 12.5 meters tall local police and
doctors alike were left scratching their
heads what had happened to these people
clearly something horrible had been done
to them but there was no actual evidence
of a crime no one had been murdered and
there was no evidence of forced entry at
any of the victims homes there was
however one other piece to the crooked
puzzle just before a victim was found
their place of residence would visibly
degrade and warp the structure itself
breaking in places until portions
collapsed in or became slanted roofs
would tilt at an unsafe angle chimneys
would fold over and door frames would
twist until no ordinary person could
pass through them safely this happened
every 12 years for decades and none of
the people of tembe could do anything
about it in fact they rarely ever so
much as spoke of it terrified of
admitting the truth of their town's
curse in so many words instead they
spoke about the phenomenon in innuendo
meaningful glances and pleas to keep
loved ones company at night and through
a simple children's rhyme one doctor
tasked with treating survivors of the
horror decided to do something as the 12
year mark began to approach once more he
reached out to a researcher he had known
years ago a man who specialized in the
unexplained things that modern medicine
had no answer for this man had left
medicine behind and was now working for
the scp foundation at the time of
contact there were approximately six
months to go until the phenomenon would
begin to strike once more the foundation
needed to act quickly in order to
collect more information and hopefully
find a way to stop the terror of tembi
once and for all with about a month to
go until the danger would reappear a
member of d-class personnel referred to
as d-209 was placed in a
foundation-owned house in town audio and
visual equipment were installed
throughout the house in order to monitor
it for any anomalous activity and to
make sure d-209 remained at his post for
the first month of his stay d-209 did
not experience anything unusual he spent
his time drinking tea baking pies and
catching up on his reading he even
thanked the foundation for the
unexpected staycation unfortunately on
his 43rd day in tembi things changed as
d209 sat in bed reading a novel by the
lamplight the camera feed in the living
room began to glitch a vertical
distortion appeared with a jagged
pattern that began to make its way
across the room from the front door it
was as if something was coming inside
but the camera could not pick up its
image the distortion continued through
the hallway until the camera placed
there cut out entirely
suddenly closed his book as the sound of
scratching came from the floor below he
began to slowly climb out of bed
listening for further sounds as the
entity continued to make its way through
the house toward him movement was
apparent on the video feed but there was
too much interference for any image of
the creature to be made out d-209 froze
in his tracks as he heard footsteps slow
and certain coming up the stairs toward
him he ran to the window attempting to
pry it open and make an escape but it
would not budge with increasing
desperation he grabbed his bedside lamp
and threw it at the window attempting to
shatter the glass the lamp broke apart
but the window remained stubbornly
intact as he scrambled for an escape
route something knocked at his bedroom
door d-209 called out toward the door
who is it who's there but there was no
response identify yourself still
whatever stood on the other side said
nothing holding the remains of the lamp
in one hand as a makeshift weapon d-209
slowly reached for the doorknob and
opened the door with a sudden pop every
light bulb in the vicinity burst
including foundation provided
floodlights positioned outside of the
house there was the sound of snapping
and then an agonized scream the camera
adjusted to the lack of light in the
room allowing for a clear image of d209
he was wailing and holding his right arm
which appeared to be broken just above
the elbow the arm began to stiffen and
elongate indicating impossibly fast bone
growth screw this you're not taking me
i'm getting out of here alive he yelled
running down the hallway he collapsed as
another snapping sound echoed throughout
the hall my legs broken set out please
he called to someone anyone who might be
watching the feed slowly painfully he
pulled himself to his feet he lifted his
right arm to the camera showing that it
had been broken again below the elbow
pointing in the opposite direction of
the first break what are you doing help
me
he screamed
it it doesn't even hurt anymore that
can't be right i don't know what's
happening to me as he continued to yell
at the cameras he limped towards the
stairs attempting to make his way down
to the first floor he missed a step lost
his balance and fell all the way down
twelve loud snaps were heard as he went
when he landed on the ground his bones
were broken in several other places only
to be immediately set where they had
broken as he screamed he dragged himself
into the living room battling against
his own body which had become something
foreign to him his arms were growing
longer now around two meters long and
his legs stretched out of the camera's
view presumably into the hallway
suddenly he stopped crawling his eyes
widening no
no
no
no
he whimpered before suddenly being
dragged backwards out of the camera's
view due to the presence of the entity
interfering with the cameras all
visibility was lost at this point there
was however still a live audio feed the
microphones picked up an hour of
snapping and screaming until d-209
eventually went quiet then all that
could be heard was a wet sucking sound
followed by a thumping meanwhile at the
hospital 27 other victims of the entity
were lying in hospital beds as d209 met
his unfortunate fate all of the
hospitalized victims began to experience
seizures at the same time and seized for
several minutes five patients were
killed and two researchers were injured
in the chaos after the incident at the
hospital reports of a seismic event at
the edge of town began to circulate
because there had been no actual
earthquake in the area the research team
realized that this disturbance had to be
somehow related to the phenomenon they
planned to investigate in order to learn
more about the entity behind it all
which they had now officially designated
scp-783
the crooked man a team of personnel were
sent to investigate the site of the
seismic event only to find a group of
10b townsfolk clustered around the area
in a field at the south of town the
crowd refused to let the researchers
through and would not budge until one
researcher agent collins pulled out her
firearm and fired a shot into the air
the sound frightened the crowd and they
realized this mysterious foundation
really meant business where the crowd
had been agent collins could see toes
unnaturally long crooked toes poking up
out of the ground they were going to
need some help and a lot more shovels to
uncover this mystery by the next day a
dig team had uncovered a mass grave
filled with victims of scp-783
there were dozens of elongated bodies
spread throughout the five meter wide
hole stacked on top of each other with
their heads facing down and their arms
outstretched towards the bottom of the
pit their limbs had grown around each
other twisting together to the point
where they could not be removed one at a
time while trying to collect a tissue
sample from one of the bodies researcher
singer lost his balance as the ground
beneath him gave way and he fell he
attempted to find a foothold and climb
back up but fell through the gnarled
arms and down into the pit thinking
quickly agent collins grabbed a rope and
tied it around her waist she would lower
herself down into the grave and would
signal when she was ready for them to
pull her out agent collins descended
into the pit over 20 meters down before
she signaled for the team to pull her
back out then she told them what she had
seen there was something down there the
entrance to another location beneath all
of the bodies someone asked if there was
any sign of researcher singer colin
shook her head face growing pale she
hadn't seen him down there he was gone
agent collins was granted a temporary
leave of absence and a d-class
d-2172 was selected for further
exploration of the anomalous mass grave
he was outfitted with a retractable
harness communication and video
equipment as well as a photo ionization
detector a geiger counter a basic
survival kit a firearm and ammunition
d2172 was then lowered into the pit via
a crane after 12 meters of descent there
was no longer any visible light inside
the pit and d 2172 switched on his
headlamp a few moments later
d-2172 began tugging on the tether
demanding to be lowered more quickly
when asked why he insisted someone just
touched my back at 18 meters down
d2172 began to feel a sense of confusion
and dizziness unable to tell which
direction he was going at this point in
the pit gravity had inverted forcing
d-2172 to climb upward in order to
continue moving down as he crossed into
another world there was daylight visible
here again as
d2172 climbed out from within the mass
of bodies there he found a seemingly
identical version of the town of tembi
he was instructed to take soil samples
and the monitoring researcher noticed
something odd on the video feed there
were marks in the dirt around the grave
that appeared to have been made by
fingers pulling across the ground they
decided not to relay this to d2172
after the soil samples came up normal
d2172 was instructed to walk to a nearby
cottage and look for any sign of the
missing researcher singer he knocked on
the door and with no answer let himself
in he saw no one inside and began to
walk through in the bedroom on the wall
there was a charcoal sketch of a
humanoid figure holding a staff of some
kind command ordered him to approach the
drawing but he protested saying he felt
incredibly uncomfortable looking at it
he relented and began to approach but as
he did the quality of the video feed
began to degrade until it was filled
with static
d2172 was then permitted to leave the
cottage and further explore this copycat
village while walking further into the
village
d2172 spotted a work boot on the ground
he picked it up and found it was a match
for the one researcher singer had been
wearing he followed the path to another
house the door of which was wide open he
walked inside to find signs of a
struggle an overturned couch and table a
hole in the wall the broken pieces of a
lamp scattered on the floor the kitchen
was just as much of a mess and as he
investigated it further he found a pool
of blood on the floor with significant
blood splatter on the walls and counter
it looked like someone had been attacked
with a weapon likely a knife indeed as
he looked d 2172 spotted a butcher's
block with only one empty slot the one
that should have held a meat cleaver the
investigation led him to a locked door
covered in scratches he broke it down
and nearly fell down the stairs into the
darkened basement instructed to head
down into the basement
d-2172 switched on his headlamp drew his
weapon and descended into the darkness
the basement was empty except for a
bloody meat cleaver and a piece of pant
leg caught inside an exhaust vent
leading out of the house the pants
resembled those worn by singer before
his fall d 2172 peered into the vent for
a closer look but was startled by the
sight of something scuttling out of
sight whatever it was it was fleshy and
it was not something he cared to see
more of
d2172 continued on his expedition
walking north and away from the town
limits of tembi somehow in spite of this
he wound back up at the south side where
he had emerged from the pit but
something was different there were no
bodies no open grave and no tethered
harness that he had taken off when he
climbed out he was trapped the harness
had not been retracted so where had it
gone command could not determine its
exact location but proposed that d2172
had entered another anomalous area and
was not in fact back where he started he
was instructed to follow the road back
retracing his steps until he wound up at
the pit again as he walked he commented
that he had not yet seen a single living
thing in this place then as he heard the
sound of rustling leaves he turned
toward it to find the corpse of an
scp-783
victim he turned back to continue on his
way only to see another victim sprawled
across the road he drew his weapon then
listening as the rustling began again he
spun around to look at the body behind
him and found that it had stretched
longer growing closer to him behind him
the other body began to snap as well he
turned to fire his weapon and saw that
this other body had stretched its neck
its head at eye level only a meter away
from his own face he fired several
rounds but the corpse did not respond
ignoring orders d-2172 took off running
into the woods leaving the road behind
he stopped to catch his breath sat down
and reloaded his firearm after eating a
quick mre and informing command of his
whereabouts he set back off on his
journey through the forest after 14
minutes of walking he began to feel
movement under the ground short sharp
bursts of motion reverberating through
the earth he could also hear a thumping
sound coming from beneath him on the
video feed command saw what appeared to
be a silver birch tree lifting out of
sight then dropping down back into the
forest shaking the ground on impact
d-2172 was instructed to approach the
object as command quickly realized that
this was no tree as he approached
another similar object landed near him
he fired his weapon at it and blood
began to dribble from the wound a scream
ringing out high above him not knowing
what else to do he ran as fast as he
could begging for help from command for
someone to do something to get him out
of there as d2172 ran out of the forest
making his way back to town another one
of the long pale objects knocked him
onto his back he looked up now able to
see what it was without the trees in his
way when he saw it he couldn't help but
scream it was researcher singer or at
least it had once been researcher singer
he had become something else
something unthinkable his body was up in
the sky
balancing on enormous impossibly long
fingers the creature that had once been
singer shrieked lifting a finger and
preparing to bring it down on d-2172
he fired several shots but none hit so
again he turned and ran he reached the
main road and kept running tasting bile
in the back of his throat and feeling
his lungs begin to burn he couldn't stop
if he stopped the creature would grab
him in those awful fingers and he didn't
want to think about what would happen
next then he saw it the pit the bodies
his way out he sprinted toward the pit
almost there when a screech rang out and
a massive finger knocked him aside the
video feed was lost with only the sound
of d2172 screaming and running away
after this d-2172 was considered lost
and attending researcher dr peterson
ordered that the team pull his harness
back out agent collins protested saying
they had no evidence of
d2172's death peterson relented and they
waited for the signal eventually it came
two tugs on the tether
d-2172 asking to be pulled out but when
they pulled the tether an empty harness
emerged something was caught on it
holding it in the pit as the team tried
to draw it out it was d 2172's hand
gripping the harness as hard as it could
the harness broke free from his grasp
and his hand flailed searching for his
chance at escape another d-class rushed
to help grabbing a hold of 2172's hand
another d-class joined in along with dr
lafayette and private audi and the group
worked together to pull the fallen man
from the pit only as they pulled they
realized that only his arm had come out
and it was continuing to come more and
more and more of his arm stretching out
to three meters in length bending and
snapping at gruesome angles they were
too late after all he was already gone
despondent the group released him and he
sank back down into the pit with the
rest there is currently no way for the
foundation to remove the crooked man
from tembi for containment instead they
must maintain a strong presence in the
town monitoring the community via a
temporary site five this area includes
two houses and a building near the local
hospital their foundation officers will
track any signs of scp-783 activity as
well as continue to research the
entity's nature and any potential
weaknesses it may have in the event that
scp-783 becomes active all of its
victims must be removed from the site of
the attack their bodies must be
incinerated and they will be added to
the case file for now there is not much
anyone can do but wait and see because
the cycle isn't broken yet it's only a
matter of time the crooked man is coming
back to do his crooked deeds be thankful
the foundation knows what everybody
needs if you want to stay yourself
protect your muscle flesh and bone then
you'd better heed this warning
don't stay home at night alone
now go check out scp-2316
the bodies in the water and
scp-966 sleep killer for more unsettling
anomalies from the scp foundation